hello they reject nation I'm Greg I'm
John we're gonna watch from Jason's
request top reward every request JD who
has saved this channel more than you
guys will ever realize so many ways he
literally sucked Johnson easily said his
message here's the next video requests I
joined a film Club called kick the
ladder they play a game where they roll
three pairs of dice 6820 sided that
decides what kind of film you make each
week then we all get together on Mondays
and watch them they are all 60 seconds
these are my best five films that I made
but I thought you could promote the
website guys go check out kick the
ladder
ATL Thunderdome calm as they're not
taking submissions nationally and
internationally you just tagged the
video with the rule code and your videos
can be viewed as part of the series each
week it is to encourage filmmaking in
each rule code hones a different skill
each short film is 60 seconds long and I
act in two of them that should at least
make it halfway entertaining for you
well if you guys understand what the
hell he's talking about that whole first
paragraph promotion complete not a
sponsored video so this first one is
called debatable
[Music]
hey that was fun that was cute that was
cute
earlier the girl I was I was Babel the
here Jason oh yeah Jason Dolan case you
guys there hey man she smacked him with
some Star Wars knowledge Darth Sidious
is not a Jedi yeah when he wasn't
talking yeah I could hear you know I
feel like you look at somebody and you
hear I'm a little closer so I kind of
feted him out of the both of them I
would love this video you can go back
and watch like multiple times I would
imagine that pick up stray quotables I
mean either way I thought that was
really funny it's a great representation
of the pop-culture life that we live in
we just can't agree we have to fight and
I like the ending note - of like we
agree when you find something to
disagree on it's the only way we could
talk to each other yeah some people
thrive on that tension good social
commentary there JD next one's called
technobabble
[Music]
Maria playing Chopin
oh it's like a humanoid version of an
Alexa that's crew lady till then
[Music]
oh here we go with that Dave you know it
makes sense to there we go that path but
I like the idea that she was like
jealous of the technology yeah she wants
to be the only machine for your
household expedition has Maria never
been around a cellphone before has she
never been around her owners I'm cuter
was it a commentary on people who do all
like the housework for us that Latinos
will rebel that you're white man
commentary on it cuz that's how I read
it you're racist for our machines just
killing for our attention and they're
all just fighting each other for our
attention so much that we're drowning
and choking on them there are many ways
to look into this I think mine is the
correct way probably because Jason Dolan
has a Mexican mate oh well yeah okay
they say write what you know all right
watchin breakable prequel to unbreakable
every night we go to sleep mine next to
each other
face between us slowly expands into this
Grand Canyon
our relationship is an echo than what it
once was people we were learning that
beautiful strangers
[Music]
days together
[Music]
three years three years gone
for example arsonist
each piece is place they not getting any
longer
there's nothing left to fix I won't make
us any stronger geez you started off so
funny Jason and now this has gotten
progressively darker right I don't get
on YouTube for dramatic shorts all right
I thought that was beautiful
nyah Kate I thought it was beautiful too
yes my favorite surfer yeah that's
probably my number one what did you
think of it oh I mean I really enjoyed
it had like a compelling simplicity
about it I mean I love the framing
device of the literal frame of the
puzzle and this slowly like I've made me
wonder whether they did that with an
actual camera trick or whether they
manipulated the image in post but even
so I thought you could probably do this
all in camera in a pretty clever way and
the monologue I thought was really well
delivered you know I thought she had a
lot of vulnerability and life in that
little you know subtle performance yeah
I also really loved the idea of the
puzzle was making me ponder because I
feel like normally they would probably
do it in Reverse alike as you complete
the puzzle more color comes in the frame
but it's like the darkness is consuming
it's like the pieces of life or
overlapping yeah light oh yeah that was
that was a great metaphor that was a
good vegetable storytelling I really
like that one JT yeah don't worry buddy
it's all downhill from here someone give
this man a feature relatable
[Music]
poor earnings that's not gonna happen I
just found out oh my god I cannot
believe this
you need to tell me that we're part of
some of the theories secret government
experiment we pray off the floor
actually guess what I did a 23andme and
it turns out we have a fourth sister
what is she saying
Wow six toughness
[Music]
that's interesting there's this thing on
the flash where they have access to
multiple earths multiverses so
oftentimes is character named Harrison
wells who is the doctor on the show and
you constantly see multiple versions of
him interact and they dislike other
tears once in a while but it's usually
that character and that's what that
reminded me of he had this concept that
could have been like you know deep and
thought-provoking which made it really
funny and I mean I wonder too how you
made this because I could see some of
like the visuals stitching and it seems
like you must have gone some kind of
old-school route and splicing all these
images together yeah this is the one
that made me the most curious perhaps
about like how did you do it because I
could tell it some of it has to be it
almost looked like film being cut and
then matched in different places or you
could probably do that digitally too but
it was weird it's like I could tell the
trickery had been done but I couldn't
quite tell how that's probably easier
with black and white in some way to do
that trickery - yeah you only got tones
to worry about I mean I thought like the
first girl was okay looking I thought
the second girl was like really good
looking but then the third girl and not
so much with the fourth is a Australian
one yeah where'd you get these actresses
I don't know man where'd you get six
identical twin sisters to be in your
film they were identical Oh
we added to the comedy here hahaha
did the decipherable
[Music]
snap oh my god Jason you know some might
argue that that would have worked better
in a longer format
I think shorter that should have been
30-second yeah yeah you could have even
snapped that even harder and once I
figured out what was going on it's not
only there was a twist
what was the voice JD that's the first
time I've seen Jason play a character so
it took a moment to get used to but I
think that was a character he played a
character and uh the first one
Deborah da Dada but did you realize you
but he was mostly just yelling and the
superinten argument Jason is really calm
and mellow and nice you mean by
charactery because he played psychopath
with an East Coast accent yeah it's good
that's a character I like the idea
though that this guy who is looking into
the disappearance of people meets the
dude with a conspiracy theory and then
he's letting him on the conspiracy
they're really he's the killer yes it
was ironic and that immediately flips it
right yeah I know soon you're going is
this aliens or even true or is this just
a serial killer mo yeah range and he
thinks he's gotten these alien messages
you know I believe these are all proof
of concepts for films Jason Dylan's
trying to get off the ground
the Dola verse the cinematic Dola verse
you can use that if you pay me beyond
your play let me on your pledge this is
what you're getting for the place which
one was your favorite job my favorite
ooh which one was my favorite it's a
toss-up between the puzzle pieces one
and the last one with Jason and his
crazy killer bees so endeared by Jason's
crazy killer mine has to be debatable
and the puzzle one okay okay I like that
we bookended this experience with two
Jason's
yeah it shows a wide variety of genre
you can explore Jason yeah man all right
Jon tell them where to go guys guys
ATL Thunderdome dot-com this is now an
international
community of filmmakers so grab that
rule code and go contribute some art get
your stuff scene maybe will react to it
if jason wants us to you can subscribe
to the real rejects like that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is out and
check us out on patreon we got TV show
watch along with highlights included as
well as timecode so you can sync the
whole show we got music videos we got a
whole bunch of exclusive content come
become patronage check today and we'll
catch you on the next one - Jason just
wanted to say we love you it's wonderful
to see your chops and the next time
we're on we need to recreate the
debatable sketch but on camera during a
reaction so that all the comments can
come back about how we're just talking
over the reaction but that'll get us so
much engagement that video makes so much
money you could produce a hundred sixty
second short film ATL Thunderdome calm I
don't know how to stop the video unless
you say it's done what do we do now oh
no I have spoken
mandalorian